there is something very very broken in
this country it's not just on the left
it's on the right it's on the left and
it's bad for us
and what that is is that people
are existing in these little bubbles
where they don't want to hear
other points of view they're becoming
increasingly like get out of my way if
you disagree with me it's breaking up
families it's breaking up friendships
and i want to just go back and tell you
a couple of stories and then i'll get to
this weekend and why this triggered this
moment for me
but this epidemic you talk about like a
pandemic this is a pandemic
it's a pandemic of an inability to just
listen to someone you disagree with just
hear their point of view have a real
conversation have friends have family
members that you may not see eye to eye
on everything if we can't do that
we're in some serious serious trouble
here so i'm putting the hot topics aside
for a moment and i want to share
something with you when i was younger
i was in my 20s and this this theme has
kind of come with me throughout my life
i was in my 20s i was working at a bar i
don't know if you've ever worked at a
bar hard work i think i shared with you
it was a two-story lounge
bar was downstairs all the tables were
upstairs it was a lot of work
but i met someone there a friend of mine
at the time she was great we clicked i'm
not someone typically who clicks with
new people but we did you know how it is
sometimes working the same shifts kind
of in the same
scene
um we became friends
and i i wasn't talking about politics a
lot back then i was in the restaurant
business i was thinking about doing some
acting was before i even taught school i
didn't know what i wanted to do i was a
floater i was like i went to grad school
i have a master's degree i don't want to
use what do i do and i just kind of
floated around
so we went out to dinner one night and
we got into politics which was very odd
she felt very differently from me about
everything she was a really hard left
you know makes bernie sanders kind of
look like a conservative kind of gal
which was okay
i didn't know all that at the time but
we kind of had a great conversation and
i went home thinking like wow i learned
something new about her
didn't affect how i saw her or like
didn't affect me wanting to or not
wanting to be her friend
i thought it was really healthy it felt
really healthy for me to have that
conversation and like be challenged and
didn't get contentious at all no arguing
well
i got it the next day and i'll never
forget it i had gotten a message from
her that said that
she felt violated i'll never forget that
word she felt violated by my opinions
violated
and it kind of shook me we had been
friends for
several years
i couldn't imagine what i had said that
was so
out there to her or that was so
would cause someone to use the word
violated
and truthfully it wrecked the friendship
she kind of dropped me like a hot potato
after that and it was it was one of
those moments where yes you're like that
wasn't really your friend but that
doesn't make it any easier to kind of
swallow in the moment
and you're like what's going on here
because i grew up in new york city i was
always outnumbered i even wrote a book
called outnumbered i always was somebody
who listened to other people talk about
politics and stuff and i didn't agree
but it was all right you know they were
my friends we had common interests we
had this or that so this was really new
that was the first time i really felt
someone kind of say you see the world
differently and i just that's not gonna
work for me
okay
a couple years later i
started doing fox news hits and i had
another friend at the time we had been
friends for four or five years
and
i i never
made facebook political at the time it
was my personal page
she was very political and i knew that
about her her facebook was kind of
covered and all this stuff you know
occupy wall street at the time was big i
remember pro abortion rallies there was
it was just littered with all of this
stuff and i would see some of it and be
like oh man i don't agree with that but
whatever it was what it was that was
part of who she was she was passionate
about it and my page had nothing on it
like that it was just you know pictures
of my family my friends going out
and i remember that when i posted uh
when i started doing fox i started just
promoting those appearances and i would
just say like hey i'm heading on
sean hannity showed at nine whatever
whatever the time was at the time
i'll never forget got a message from her
i can't be friends with someone who
would go on fox news
i said you don't even know what i'm
gonna say
you don't even know what i'm gonna say
didn't matter
did not matter that tunnel
needed to be maintained that tunnel of
like these are the people
who see the world the way i do this
person is over here i'm uncomfortable
really
that quickly
i was just sort of cycled out wasn't as
as pronounced as the former situation
where it was like i can't talk to you
ever again but i was clearly not part of
the team after that
so those were two experiences that i
kind of swallowed and i started to
realize something was wrong and when i
wrote my book outnumbered i actually
wrote about being able to walk in
someone else's shoes and look around and
experience the world you know and have
these conversations and not be like
willing to cut people off because i
realized this was real this was real and
this was happening um
now you fast forward a bunch of years
and you remember i was on the view
um i got fired from that job that's
public right i don't know the details as
to why but regardless it was not it
wasn't an easy pill to swallow that
firing because i went to work one day
and didn't have a job the next with no
explanation so you might imagine that
you might be hmm what happened there
regardless i made a decision when i left
that i was gonna not
take that out on you know producers or
cast i i kind of kept close with them
and i kind of said to myself you know
what i knew there was somebody in that
establishment who's not there anymore
who was just a bad seed
and i knew something pretty sinister had
gone on and had nothing to do with me
and or my work and i kind of just made a
decision to take the high road on that
which is why you'll never be able to
find any
go go ahead google it you'll never be
able to find me you know saying bad
stuff about the show when i left that's
just not who i am that's not the game i
play when i'm done i'm done move on
smile don't take that negative energy
with you
you may remember i stayed in touch with
with the ladies for a long time actually
right up until i appeared last year um
and if you'll remember i went on the
show and we all saw that unfold
i get on the show i'm just have a
different opinion about
what is apparently a sacred cow which is
the vaccine
heaven forbid anyone disrupt big
pharma's sleep
and suddenly i was the enemy
i was the bad guy it was like
misinformation shut shut down and the
segment you're a bad person really all i
was saying was hey
everyone make your own decision this is
not ideal for me i don't need it it's
not been advised for me so at that
moment i also realized
if you touch one of these
sacred topics
and you you kind of tread on that
you'll be excommunicated in two seconds
too why couldn't we have that
conversation i was left thinking you
invited me on why couldn't we sit and
and debate that out would have been a
great topic to sit and hear people
pro-mandate anti-mandate that fantastic
conversation for that moment in time
where the mandates were just coming out
people felt very differently there were
people around the country who loved it
who hated it that was a moment
for different points of view to gather
and talk
no couldn't have it for whatever reason
that topic was sacred i think there are
other topics like that i think the topic
of gender i think the topic of race i
think there's certain untouchables
and if you touch them
you're gonna get burned someone's gonna
just burn you up they're gonna burn you
up so that was my moment to be burnt up
but i couldn't believe it i was like wow
all these years of just maintaining
that respectful like polite
up in a minute
now this doesn't only happen on the left
okay the reason i'm bringing it up is
because it's also seeping into the right
do i think it happens more times on the
left i do
do i think it has happened more in my
life from folks on the left i do that's
my personal experience
but you may also remember that i worked
at fox news
okay
i wasn't always popular toward the end i
took an opinion
i felt like
trump sometimes got in his own way with
the tweets and all that stuff i didn't
like all the personal attacks i felt
like it distracted from
some of the really good policy work that
he was doing and i kind of wanted him to
just be like can you just give yourself
a minute
sit back and let that positive moment
happen so i shared it i'm an opinion
person that's my job
i also didn't see
evidence
of a stolen election and i was i was
asking so i made it my job to come out
and say okay
prove it to me show me where is it you
know i'm not seeing in the court
documents i'm not seeing that this
happened i'm not they're not alleging
this in court so i was asking you know
folks like john ellis and like hey like
why aren't they making this allegation
in court if it's true what's going on
here i was really truly when i say this
truly trying to just get to the bottom
of what was going on and why was there
this discrepancy between what i was
being told by gop governors and what the
president was saying and was there
something wrong here maybe there maybe
there was something stolen and i needed
to i was missing something so it was
like what am i missing what's going on
here
well
that led to me being excommunicated by
some in the conservative movement it
wasn't a popular position with everyone
and i saw an instant like change in some
people like she's a traitor
she's a traitor get her out of here
she's she's an anti-trumper which if you
listen to my commentary was absurd
because i was agreeing with him 90 of
the time no one agrees with anyone 100
of the time that's just then you're a
robot or you're a paid or unpaid
spokesman for the for the person in
office which i wasn't right
so
that was a moment for me that was that
was challenging because i was like i had
gone through my whole life thinking oh
this is this is something that happens
on the left and it wasn't just something
happening on the left this was now
something happening on the right as well
that's a problem right especially
because in my view people on the right
have been really good about talking
about diversity of thought on college
campuses and all of these things that
have been championed for so long and now
i was seeing in my own life wow when it
comes time to actually just have an
opinion that doesn't quite jive
man there were a lot of people with big
microphones that were ready to throw me
right off that titanic i mean really
so it was it was a learning experience
and an important one if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]